[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
CAIT FLANDERS: This
is really cool.
I also just have
to say it's really
neat coming from Canada--
I'm from a small island on
the west coast of Canada.
So to be standing
at Google London
is kind of wild right now just
talking about my little book.
So my name is Cait Flanders.
Thank you to Nicola
for inviting me here.
I have been a personal
finance blogger for the past--
gosh, like seven or eight
years at this point.
My last job that I had
was I was managing editor
of a financial startup
for about three years,
and I've done a lot
of freelance writing
in the personal finance space
for other financial startups,
different banks,
and stuff like that.
And now I am an author, which
is pretty wild, like I said,
because I'm just
from a little island
on the west coast of Canada.
And now you guys are holding a
book that became a "Wall Street
Journal" bestseller, and every
day I'm just sort of like,
what?
But it's really amazing
to be here today.
So I will take you a little
bit-- step backwards.
Having a career in
personal finance
is something that I
never, ever set out to do.
I can honestly say,
looking back on my life
and the different
interests that I've had,
I never thought that
that is something
I would do-- that I would be
writing about how people could
be better with money.
And I say that because I have
not always been good at money.
So I grew up, very fortunately,
with a family that talked
about money all the time.
Actually, we say it--
it's a line in the book,
but it's true.
So my dad's a sailor, and
when your dad is a sailor,
no topic of
conversation is taboo.
You basically talk
about everything.
But money was the
biggest one, so I
remember things
growing up, and my dad
would tell me things,
like how much he
made, how much my mom made,
what they paid for their house.
And actually knowing things,
like how much stuff costs--
I remember going to
the grocery store
and them actually pointing
out how much things cost.
So we knew, like, OK,
for a family of five,
this is what groceries cost.
I remember looking at their bank
accounts, all kinds of stuff.
We talked about
money all the time.
My dad was also someone
who had this really--
I will say annoying
when you're 13, 14,
15 years old-- habit
of every morning,
he would read the newspaper.
And when he would find
an article about anything
personal finance
related-- so whether it
was about retirement savings
accounts, real estate markets,
the economy, just anything
that was going on.
My dad would cut them out
and leave them on my bed
for me to read when I
got home from school.
So I would walk into the
house, walk into my room,
and see these, and immediately
roll my eyes and groan,
and be like, I have no interest
in reading this right now--
and unfortunately didn't.
I will say that even though my
dad talked to me about money
all the time, I still
made a lot of mistakes.
And I think that's sort of just
something that happens in life.
We don't do everything just
the way that our parents
have hoped that we would.
So I will say right now--
so I'm 32 years old.
When I was 25, I was maxed out
with close to $30,000 of debt,
and that was basically
just consumer debt.
So it wasn't even student loans.
I didn't even have a
great excuse for why
I was in that amount of debt.
And if I were to switch
that into pounds--
you guys might know this stuff.
I'd say it was probably
like 16,000, 17,000 pounds
of just consumer debt.
And when I say maxed out,
I was truly maxed out.
I had $100 left
in my bank account
and $100 left on one
of my credit cards.
And I somehow had to make
that last me for six weeks.
So I had no choice at
that point but to start
taking my finances seriously
and to start paying off my debt.
And so I started
this little blog
that I wrote anonymously
for a long time
that I thought was
just going to be
this little place
on the internet
where I could document my
debt repayment journey.
No one was supposed to read it.
I never intended to ever have
an audience or readership
or anything like that.
All I wanted to do--
and it was as
boring as this-- is
I would write these
weekly spending reports.
So weekly spending reports
literally looked just like--
Monday, I spent
$2.91 at Starbucks.
Tuesday, I spent
Maybe I spent some money on
groceries or something else.
Wednesday, Thursday.
That's all it was.
I would post these every Sunday.
There was nothing
exciting about them,
but then people started
reading them and commenting.
And I was like, what?
What's going on here?
And then I found
this whole world
of personal finance bloggers--
a lot of people
doing the same thing.
So this was 2011,
2012, a couple of years
after the kind of
financial crash.
So I think everyone has
sort of finally coming
to this place of
like, OK, it's time
to really start getting
serious with what
we're doing with our money.
What I will say about being
maxed out at that point
is that it weighed
so heavily on me
that I became extremely
aggressive about my debt
repayment approach.
So I can't say that I had the
best techniques for the way
that I paid off my debt.
I also look back at it and
think that it was extremely--
not just aggressive.
I was really hard on myself.
So the things I used to say
to myself when I was in debt
was like, you're a bad person.
You've screwed up
all your chances
of having a strong
financial future--
kind of like I deserve
to be punished and not
have any sort of fun
money or free money
because I had just gotten myself
into this horrible situation.
And so I just deserved whatever
it took to get out of it.
And I paid off my
debt in two years,
and that sounds great on paper.
But the problem then was that
throughout those two years,
I hadn't taken the time to
learn why I had actually gotten
into debt in the first place.
So I didn't understand
what my habits were.
I didn't know actually what
I had been overspending
on all those years before.
I kind of had this record
of the past two years
when I was paying off my
debt, but I didn't really
know anything about
myself as a consumer.
Because just for
those two years,
I was just anti-consumption,
anti-everything,
which-- we can talk about
that more in the mindful
zone of that now.
But I didn't know
anything about myself,
so on top of being
super aggressive,
being hard on myself, and
not learning anything,
it's not that surprising to
me that once I was debt free,
I actually just went back
to spending basically
all of my money.
So there were months
when I was paying off
my debt where I would put up to
55% of my income towards debt
repayment, and that was great.
But again, a little
bit too aggressive--
like not quite something
that could be sustainable.
Because again, I
had no fun money.
I didn't allow myself
to do anything just
for pure pleasure, like the
simplest things that you enjoy.
I didn't let myself
do any of it.
So there were months back then--
55% of my income
going towards debt.
And in the first year
that I was debt free--
and I should have been set
up to have this much more
successful financial future.
I should have been able to
achieve all kinds of goals.
And instead, I was saving
maybe 5% of my income.
And I would write
these blog posts then
where I would say at the
beginning of every month
that I wanted to be
saving 20% of my income.
And then at the
end of every month,
I would be like, oh,
hey, guys, remember
when I said that thing?
I actually only
saved like 3% or 5%.
I think the most was about
12% in an entire year.
And it's not that I
was saving nothing,
but it's that writing that
down every single month
did not feel good.
It didn't fell good to share it
and have to tell people that I
had not achieved my goal.
But also, it just
didn't feel good for me
because I knew that
I could do better
and that I really wanted to.
So I will tell you
about this challenge
that I decided to sort
of set out for myself.
But everyone upfront-- a
question is always like, oh,
why did you start doing it?
What was the goal?
And I'm like, to
be honest, I think
we wish it was sort of
like a more dramatic story,
or we wish that there were
some huge rock bottom moment
or something like that.
But I think for me, something
I've learned about myself
is that I usually
create change in my life
after I've been thinking about
it for a really long time
and eventually get
to a place where
I'm just really uncomfortable
and I have to make a change.
So for me, all it was
was that once a month,
for 12 months in a
row, I would think,
I can do better than this.
I don't know exactly
what that looks like yet,
but I'm not happy
with what I just did.
I know I can do better.
So what does that look like?
And then after a year of
being debt free, not that
surprisingly, I had
another money conversation
with my family.
My sister, at the
time, was 20 years old.
I was 29, and we're sitting
in my parents' house.
We're all just kind
of hanging out,
and my sister starts
telling us about how
she had just bought some camera
or something for like $500.
Keep in mind, she's a full
time university student.
She is working part
time, but she doesn't
have a ton of extra money.
So we're all just
kind of picking at her
and being like, oh, you should
save more of your money.
Don't spend it all.
And she goes, yeah, but
I save 20% of my income,
so I can do whatever
I want with the rest.
And so first of
all, I'm like, wait.
What?
How has my sister figured
this out before me?
How's she saving 20% on
her part time salary,
and I can't even do that
making a decent income
at a financial startup?
OK.
But then the words that
came out of my mouth
were just automatic.
I didn't even think of
them before I said them.
I just said to her, yeah,
but you live at home.
Do you really need
80% of your income,
or could you live on less?
And then it was one
of those things where
I have no idea what anybody else
said for the next five minutes.
And in my head, I'm like, whoa.
Where did that
question come from?
Why have I never
asked myself that?
Do I need 90% or
95% of my income,
or could I be living
on less than that?
And so the wheels just
started turning from there,
and within a couple of
weeks, I just sort of
wrote down these
rules for something
that I called a shopping ban.
When I think about
the shopping ban now,
I sort of wish I had called it
something different because it
sounds incredibly
restrictive up front.
It's like, no shopping.
You can't buy anything.
That's not what the goal
was, and that's not even
what that year looked like.
I just sort of had
this idea that I
didn't want to buy anything
unless I absolutely needed it.
And also knowing I had
never shopped like that
before, I had never spent
money like that before--
waited until I actually
needed something.
I used to be someone who made
a lot of preemptive purchases,
right?
You just buy things because you
think, I'll need it one day.
It will help me
in that scenario.
But I never waited until
I just needed the thing,
and then you buy the thing.
So I just wrote
these rules down,
and I will say-- so there
were three different lists.
The first list was the
things I was allowed to buy.
So basic stuff-- you could
call it even consumables.
So I was obviously
allowed to buy groceries.
I could put gas in my car, buy
toiletries when you run out
of them.
I'm always like, if you run out
of deodorant and toothpaste,
everyone in your life wants
you to buy more of that stuff,
so please buy more of it.
So anything that you are using
often and run out of-- buy it.
Buy more of the
stuff that you need.
That's fine when
you run out of it.
The things I could not buy--
that list was a lot longer.
So I couldn't buy clothes,
shoes, books, magazines,
electronics, things
for around the house.
And then I added take-out
coffee to that list
of things I couldn't buy.
And I will say I'm
not a personal finance
writer who's like, you're
not allowed your $5 latte.
I just had a $5 latte--
well, a $5 Canadian latte.
So I'm not one of those
people who says that.
I was just at the
point with my finances
where I was no longer
comfortable with how much I
was spending on it.
And I was doing it
strictly out of habit.
It wasn't because I genuinely
wanted the coffee even.
It's just this thing
that I did all the time,
and so I was just
still doing it.
So I was like, no more
take-out coffee, either.
I also created this
other short list
because I decided to do
this for an entire year.
So I started trying to
look ahead a little bit
and just think of a
few things that I might
need in that upcoming year.
So one was--
I had five weddings to go to,
and I'm not really someone
who dresses up in general.
So I was like, I need an
outfit-- so one outfit--
a dress, shoes, or
whatever, and that will
be for all of the weddings.
I knew that I had no
kind of winter boots,
and actually, these
are the ones I bought.
So I bought these in 2014
and just still wear them
now, which is great.
And there was something
else I really wanted.
It was if I could
save the money,
I really wanted to buy
a new bed that year
because my bed was 13 years old.
And I think because it
was a bigger ticket item,
I could never seem to save and
actually afford to replace it.
It's so interesting to look
back at the psychology of that.
In all my years
previous, I was so
quick to spend $20
here, $30 there,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
How quickly that
stuff adds up, and I
could have just had $1,000
to buy a bed back then.
But anyway, so I was like,
if I can save the money,
I would really
like to buy a bed.
That just was important to me.
So I started this challenge
on my 29th birthday.
So it was July of 2014.
Right up front, I
also decided to start
sort of a secondary
challenge, which again, I
still think or
wish I had a better
reason for why I started it.
But I just sort of got on
that kick of de-cluttering.
I definitely recognized
the fact that I'd
been spending a bunch
of money on stuff
that I probably didn't really
need, wasn't even using.
I could look around
my home and see
that I had more
than enough stuff,
and there was so much that
I wasn't wearing anymore--
I wasn't reading it,
touching it, whatever.
I just wasn't using this stuff.
So at the same time that I
decided to stop shopping,
I also decided I was
going to de-clutter, which
sounds really counterintuitive.
But it ended up being the
very weird and great challenge
to do together because
it all taught me
about becoming a more
mindful consumer in general.
So I set out to do that.
When I started
de-cluttering, I will say,
that was the very first
thing I sort of did.
Starting the shopping ban felt
easy in the first few weeks.
But when I started de-cluttering
at the exact same time,
what was so
interesting about that
was that I took inventory,
which sounds so boring.
But I took inventory of not
only the amount of stuff
that I got rid of but also
the things I was keeping.
Now, the reason that ended
up being so important--
I was strictly doing
it for a data point.
I'm so nerdy that throughout
this entire process
I was literally tracking the
percentages of how much stuff
I got rid of, how
much stuff I kept,
and it was just purely for me.
It didn't matter
for anyone else.
I was just super curious how the
numbers were going to add up.
And so the first
couple of months, I
ended up de-cluttering
43% of my belongings
in just maybe a month
and a half, two months.
And it was really easy at first,
but that list of inventory
of the things that I kept--
the reason it ended
up being so important
was because it helped
stop me from making
a lot of impulse purchases.
So throughout the
shopping ban, there
were numerous times where I
did think about buying things.
But then I was able to just
sort of mentally check and go,
you know what?
When I started this, I actually
still owned over 50 books
that I haven't even read yet.
I do not need to buy more books.
And the same thing just for
toiletries, kind of the things
you have the most of.
So when people ask
me now, well, what
should I do if I was going
to start a shopping ban?
I'm like, don't even
start one, to be honest.
Start by taking inventory
of the stuff you own.
Because I think that alone
will help people just
stop making some of
the impulse purchases
they're more inclined to make.
So I de-cluttered,
took inventory,
and then I noticed
kind of month two--
that is where the first
time things really
started to feel like they
were a little bit trickier.
And when I say this--
OK, journalists keep asking
me what the hardest part was,
and I'm like, to be
honest, the hardest part
was really changing habits.
So the things you
do all the time.
So one of the
hardest things for me
was to give up take-out coffee.
And then journalists
laugh at that sometimes,
like, oh, how silly.
What a frivolous thing.
And I'm like, no,
you don't get it.
It's not about the
take-out coffee.
It's that that is something
I was doing habitually
almost every single day.
Which meant that every single
day, I'm then in that moment
where I'm like, oh, I
want to do this thing--
oh, but I can't.
And so you have to stop
and start figuring out
what your triggers were, and
why you were thinking of doing
that, and change your reaction.
Like, I had never thought of
changing my reaction before.
I always just like,
when I thought
of getting take-out coffee,
I just immediately got it.
So it was the first
time that I really
had to start thinking about
why I was even considering
getting take-out coffee and then
changing my reaction to that.
Gosh, what was like--
so the hardest parts--
take-out coffee.
Books were the next biggest one.
And again, it's a habit.
I used to have this
really bad habit,
and it's so easy with
stuff like Amazon.
You just hear of
something online,
or you can hear
it from anywhere.
And you immediately click over,
and you go to buy the thing.
And back then, it
was like you need $25
to get the free shipping.
You just add something else
that sounds kind of OK,
get your free shipping--
bing, bang, boom.
I do that once a week
or once every two weeks.
I do not read that many books.
I really wish that I
did, but I never did.
It's very rare that I
read that many books,
but I did it all the time.
Which meant that at least
once or twice a week,
I was kind of sitting
there being like, well,
that book sounds good.
What do I do now?
And so in the
beginning, noticing
that those were the two
toughest ones for me-- that
would look different for
everyone, because everyone's
spending is so personal.
And that's why,
again, people ask me
about shopping bans or doing
something similar all the time.
And I'm like, yours is going
to look different than mine.
And what's hard for you is going
to look different than what
looked hard for me, because
everyone's are different.
The things that we have
habits for-- some of them
are kind of similar,
but often not.
Everyone's values
are so different.
So those are the toughest parts.
The changing the
habit part is what
then became the most
important thing for me.
Like with the take-out coffee--
pretty easy.
Honestly, well, and
you guys are lucky.
Like at work, it would
just be here for you.
But for me, it was
like, OK, well,
instead of going out
to get take-out coffee,
I just have to kind of leave
all the stuff for making coffee
on the counter at all times.
If it's just there,
then you do it.
And then that becomes a
habit, an enjoyable habit.
I started enjoying making
coffee every morning
and almost noticing it became
this really nice routine
because I was working remotely
for the startup that I was at.
And I would just enjoy
my kind of slow mornings
getting up, making the coffee,
kind of listening to a podcast
or something, just
relaxing a little bit,
and then starting the day.
It was so much
easier than just--
and actually, isn't that
even weird to think about?
I was working remotely,
and somehow it
used to seem easier to get
dressed and go downstairs
to get coffee rather
than just to make coffee.
But it was just a habit.
So changing that
habit was easy--
or easy over time.
The books one was tough.
I thought about buying books
for a long, long, long time.
I will say that I became very
good friends with my library.
And I actually had to get
a new credit card that year
because mine had
been compromised,
and so they have to send you
a new number and all of that.
Still to this day-- it's
been almost four years--
I do not have that credit
card number memorized.
I used to know all
of them off by heart
because it was just so
easy to do online shopping.
I still don't know
what that one is,
but I memorized my
library card number
within probably three
weeks of having it
because I used it all the time.
And then another
question I get-- so aside
from my personal habits is,
how did friends deal with it?
That's probably the
most common question
I get at any kind of
event that I do now.
What did friends do?
What did family do?
I feel super fortunate
that my friends and family
were mostly pretty supportive--
family, definitely.
I think also because
over the years, the thing
that they had watched
me do was sort
of take on these big
challenges and just do them.
Like other things I'd written
about on the blog was not
only paying off my
debt in two years,
but I also quit drinking
in those two years.
And I'm very open and honest
about that in the book.
So if you do read
it, you will find
a lot of stories about that.
And I also decided to sort
of take control of my health.
I lost 30 pounds.
I started training for
my first half marathon.
I was just doing
these big challenges.
So family was just like, oh,
yeah, you'll do this thing,
no problem.
What was more interesting with
friends is that at first I
will say our struggle was more
just that friends didn't really
seem to get the point.
So I would find out all my
friends had gone out for dinner
or something like that.
I'm like, wait,
where was my invite?
And then they'd be all
confused and be like, well,
I thought you weren't
going to dinner.
I'm like, no, I
can go to dinner.
Invite me to dinner.
I'm allowed to do that
if I want to do that.
They're like, oh, OK.
So friends seemed
confused all the time.
What was more
interesting was when
I would find myself listening
to conversations with friends
where they were talking about
how much stuff they had bought,
or like the deals
they had got, or where
they had bought something from.
And I don't think I'd ever
realized how socially normal
it is to talk about shopping.
I was really naive
when I started.
I just kind of thought
no one would care,
and it wouldn't be a big deal.
And then this is something
I also noticed, obviously,
when I quit drinking.
Drinking is very
culturally normal.
And so you're in a
lot of conversations
where now you're
like, OK, I'm not
part of this
conversation any more.
I can't add anything to it.
I can't participate in any way.
And with shopping,
I just didn't think
that was going to be a thing,
but it came up all the time.
And it can be as simple as,
where did you get your shoes?
Where did you get your bag?
Oh, what book are you
reading right now?
Where did you get it from?
Who did you hear about--
just anything.
People talk about the stuff
that they buy all the time.
And so it's not
that friends cared.
It was really that it was
one of those moments--
and I think about this a lot.
Especially when you're
sober, you often
find yourself in
situations where
you feel like the only
sober person in the room
because you genuinely are.
You're the only who
isn't participating.
And with these conversations,
it ended up being the same.
So I will say the
first six months or so
of the shopping ban were just
tough in terms of figuring out
what my habits were,
how to change them,
and then also
starting to question
a little bit more what
my values actually
were and the things
I actually did
want to be spending money on.
But it got a little bit
tougher about halfway through.
So in the book, I
talk about it a lot,
but my parents ended up
announcing that they were
getting divorced that year.
And I think it was the
first time that I really
recognized that I was more--
I'll just say an
emotional consumer.
So I think what I
realized that year
was that in the past what I
would have done was probably
drank my way through that.
I'm also pretty
honest about when
I was younger, binge
eating-- things like that.
And because I didn't have
those, and now I also
didn't have spending
as an option,
I had to do the tougher
part, which is you just
have to feel the hard feelings.
And that's not great
advice, sort of.
People are always like,
OK, if you couldn't
do that, what did you do?
And I'm like, I cried
a lot that year.
It was really not that exciting.
It wasn't a great year all
around or for all parts of it,
but it was a really hard year.
And I had to learn how to feel
feelings for the first time
and just get through it.
So what ended up getting easier
after that was finally coming
to a place where I had a goal.
I didn't have a goal,
really, when I got started.
I sort of wrote these
few things down--
I want to spend less,
and I want to save more.
And it was definitely just
this kind of financial journey
that I was on.
But then I just thought--
and the other part
of that was that I
said I wanted to also become
a more mindful consumer, which
I truly was just
kind of making up.
Like, I didn't even know
what that really meant.
I'm like, that sounds
like a good thing.
If I could be a more mindful
consumer, that sounds great.
But I didn't really
have a financial goal.
So at halfway through,
I was doing pretty good.
I was saving typically about
20% of my income every month.
I was spending a bit on travel
for the first time, which
felt great because
travel was something
I'd always wanted to do.
But I never seemed
to have the money
to do it because I was sort
of just mindlessly spending
money on whatever else.
So I was spending a bit on
travel, living on much less
than I had been before.
But then I decided--
or sort of in looking
at my finances--
realized that not only
was I living on less,
but I was also doing
a bit more freelance.
To the point that I
realized I was actually
earning the amount of money that
I was living on at that time.
So it started to become an
option to me that I could maybe
quit and either work for myself
or just figure something out.
And that is a position I had
never been in and never even
imagined being in before.
I had never thought to myself
that I would work for myself.
I grew up with parents who
worked in the public service.
And so I just--
entrepreneurship or
whatever-- it just
wasn't something I ever
aspired to or thought
would be part of my future.
But once I realized that my
spending was exactly how much I
was already earning just
on the side, I'm like, OK,
there's a little bit more
motivation here to keep going.
And I sort of kicked it into
high gear at that point.
In the last six months, I made
this decision to quit my job.
And I ended up,
on those months--
I don't know.
There were months
in there I probably
saved up to 45% of my income.
And by the end of
it had enough money
that I felt completely
comfortable quitting
and knew that, even if I could
only do it for six or eight
months, I had tons of money.
I had lined up a ton of work.
And I had tons of
money in the bank.
And that I could at least make
it work for probably six months
to a year.
And that it just would
have been worth trying.
And I was someone who never
took chances on myself before.
When I really look back at the
kind of consumer that I was,
I used to buy things for
all the wrong reasons--
and even as a drinker, too.
I wrapped so much of my
self-worth up in the wrong
things and in trying to be
someone that I actually wasn't.
And in that year, I
ended up de-cluttering
70% of my belongings.
As part of that--
I remember the
toughest part right
towards the end of
de-cluttering was
realizing that everything left
over was stuff I actually used.
But there were these
few items that I
had held onto that were
sort of for this more
aspirational version of myself.
So I used to buy books
that I would think--
I don't know, a smarter
or just more interesting
version of myself might read.
Or I'd buy clothes that a more
professional or put together
version of myself might wear.
Creative projects
were a big one.
I had so many-- everything
from a DSLR camera,
to scrapbooking stuff,
to painting stuff.
I had all these different
materials for creative projects
that I thought I
might do one day.
But I never did any of
them, because the real
me wasn't actually
interested in any of it.
And so I remember in
letting go of all of that
and sort of letting go through
that entire year of just all
the stuff that I didn't
need, I realized the things
that I actually do value and
who I really am as a person.
And it became a lot easier to
start making spending decisions
once I actually knew
who I was already.
So I don't want to cut it
short there, but I'm like,
there's more I could
say, but I don't know.
I've seen a few
faces where I'm like,
are there any questions yet?
Oh, no.
[LAUGHS]
OK, well, what I will say is
that when I finished the year,
I had quit my job.
I had lived on an average
of 51% of my income.
I saved 31% of it.
And I spent 18% on travel,
which was a lot of money.
But I'd never been
able to do that before.
And so even-- if we
had cut that out,
though, if I hadn't
spent anything on travel,
I would have saved
49% of my income.
And a lot of that
truly just came back
to making more mindful
decisions every day, every week.
Not that I was buying nothing.
I also want to say, I don't
believe that buying stuff is
bad or spending money is bad.
I buy things now,
and I spend money.
I'm on a six-week
vacation right now.
And I've bought
books since I've been
here and a few other things.
I don't think it's about that.
It really for me was about
getting to a place where
I could figure out who I was.
And it makes spending
decisions so much easier.
Because now I know when I make
a purchase it's for something
I actually need, or I really
want it in that moment.
It feels really amazing to buy
a book because you genuinely
really want to read it.
And that day you sit down and
read it in three or four hours.
That feels really good.
And that is something I
can't say about past me.
I never knew how to do that.
But yeah, I'll leave
it there for now.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
Oh.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So the only part you
haven't mentioned yet
is when you decided
to write the book
and how you went from
kind of this experiment
to becoming an author.
Can you talk a
little about that?
CAIT FLANDERS: Yeah.
OK, so the question
just being about when
I decided to write the book.
I don't know that
that was a decision.
It was this really amazing
twist of events that happened
after I finished the year.
So earlier that year, I had
done an interview with someone
at "Forbes."
And the interview was
about someone else.
She was like, I know-- because
I knew kind of everyone
in the personal finance space.
And she's like, I know that
you have a good relationship
with this person.
I'm doing a profile on them.
And I would really love a couple
of quotes of just what they
mean to the community.
So we did this great interview.
She got the quotes.
And at the end of
it, she goes, now,
when you're done doing the
thing you're doing, let me know.
We can write a profile about it.
So I reached out to
her about a month
before, because I knew
the last couple months,
especially, I was like,
I've got this in the bag.
This shopping ban thing
is just a way of life.
I'm saving as much money as
I can so I can quit my job.
This is easy.
So I emailed her to say,
hey, I'm almost done.
I'll be done soon.
Let's do the interview.
And the day it came
out, which was actually
the last day of the
shopping ban, it came out.
She emailed me the link that
morning and goes, just FYI,
these things have a
tendency to go viral.
I'm like, what?
And within two weeks, I
had been contacted by six
different literary agents.
So I never made that decision.
That was sort of
something that came after.
And it's been really
interesting, because I think,
as a writer, as a creative,
you sort of struggle with--
I didn't set out to do it.
But at the same time, I
was writing about something
that people were
obviously thinking about.
And so publishers, literary
agents just saw that.
And it just became an option.
It's sort of one of
those things, too.
It was like, quitting my job was
never the goal either, right?
And it just became an option.
It was the first time where
I was really in a position
where I could take
an opportunity
and move forward with it.
So it just became an option.
AUDIENCE: It's so
ironic that you gave up
buying books to write one.
CAIT FLANDERS: It is.
Although, I will say
about that, too, is--
I don't tell anyone to just
go out and buy the book.
I'm always like--
I talk about this now.
I buy books when I know
I'm going to read it.
So if it feels
like something you
want to read now, then buy
it, or ask your library
if they have it.
I don't know how the library
system works over here.
But in North America, you can
just go and ask your library
to get the book.
And that also helps authors.
Authors-- I don't--
not maybe over here.
But in North America,
authors actually-- like,
a small amount--
get paid out every single
time your book is checked out.
So just an FYI.
It's just as-- not
maybe just as good.
But it all helps.
It all helps.
And so I'm-- yeah.
I just always think about that.
I would never go out and
tell anyone to buy any book.
But, yeah, no,
the irony is real.
And it is not lost on me.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: What would you say
are some of the treats that
you've--
so you mentioned travel.
But just aside from
that, what would you
say that you're doing now that
you haven't done before that
is maybe a splurge or an
expense that you wouldn't
have considered, like a treat?
CAIT FLANDERS: Well, it's funny.
The word treat-- and I talk
about this a little bit
in the book.
The word treat or
treat yourself,
things like YOLO, all the
sort of different phrases
that are out there, the reason
I don't like them just sort
of in general--
not even just that we
say them to each other.
Although, part of
that that I don't like
is that I think everyone truly
wants to be saving more money.
And yet, we've created
these little phrases
where we're all encouraging
each other to spend more.
It's really weird.
So I don't like that
word, because for me, it
makes it still feel
like it's something
I shouldn't be having.
So for me, I actually believe--
I don't really have thoughts
on needs versus wants.
If you really want
something, it's just a need.
If it fits in your
budget, it's a need.
So I would say
now as a consumer,
I pretty much never buy clothes.
There's all these
things that I just
realized I don't care about.
But I do--
I mean, I buy books.
I don't buy more than I read.
But it feels really
amazing now to--
I would say I buy more
books in bookstores.
I don't buy anything
online really anymore.
And that for me has come
from this place of-- it's
so much different to
walk into a bookstore,
really read a few pages
of it, get an actual feel
for what the book is like,
and then making the decision
to buy it.
Rather than just
hearing about it,
immediately getting it online.
So I probably spend more on
books because I do it that way.
But I also-- it's
like, something
that's super weird-- or people
keep calling me a minimalist.
I'm like, I don't even know
if I would call myself one.
Because I do like
tangible stuff.
I like real books.
I don't really like e-books.
So probably just books
still, just differently.
It's just a lot different buying
them now than it used to be.
AUDIENCE: One of
the things people
say with credit cards and
online, you mentioned,
that you don't actually track
the money you're spending.
It's very easy, because
you don't actually
physically experience them.
Did you use any tricks,
like paying more
with cash or
something like this,
or any kind of similar things?
You mentioned going to actual
bookstores instead of online.
Anything else that helps?
CAIT FLANDERS: It's funny.
I love that question,
because my answer still
is not great in the sense of--
I think it's going to be
personal for everyone.
So I remember trying a cash
budget years ago, actually,
when I was trying
to pay off my debt.
And it just did not work for me.
Or at least the
way I was doing it.
I think because I had tried
to really restrict myself.
This is the amount of money
I'm allowed for two weeks.
But then things genuinely
do come up in that time.
You're like-- even if it's
only $20, you're like,
I actually really
need that money.
What am I supposed to do now?
So cash doesn't
quite work for me.
I would say now I basically
pay for everything with credit.
But it comes--
I mean, that's been a cycle.
When I was paying off my
debt, I never used my credit.
For about a year after that,
I didn't really love using it.
And then now I'm just
in a place that I'm
really comfortable
with my spending,
because I know I
won't overspend.
I trust myself and look
at my spending weekly.
And so I just know
that I'm doing OK.
But I think it's really
personal for everyone.
The one thing that I
have done for a long time
and still do to this day is
I actually put pen to paper
and write things down.
So in a journal,
I will literally
write down how much I
spend everyday and on what.
I don't do that quite
as much anymore.
But I did it for years.
Because for me, there's
something so different.
It was the same way as
publishing on the blog.
Knowing that I had to write
down the exact amounts
and put it out
there, I naturally
just started to spend less.
Because you'd see--
oh, you know what?
It actually doesn't feel
great to be spending money
on Starbucks every single day.
So maybe I'm going to cut
it down just a little bit.
So I would-- I don't know.
I'm super old school.
I love technology
for so many things.
But there's something
about spending.
Writing it down by
hand, it just helped
me become more mindful
of it over the years.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I guess it's been quite
a bit of trial and error
through the process.
My question is more
about, is there anything
over this amount of time that--
is there one thing that you
would have done differently?
Or anything that you
particularly regret around
decisions that you made?
CAIT FLANDERS: Good question.
I don't know if I would
do it differently.
I guess I actually forgot about
one story in this is that--
it was, I guess, four and a
bit months into the first year
of the shopping ban.
Because I actually
didn't even say this,
but when the first
year was over,
I ended up doing it
for a second year--
and again, just for sort of data
points, which is super boring.
But I was super
curious about things
like, how much stuff
do I actually use?
How many things of
toothpaste do I actually
use in a year, or deodorant,
or lotion, or cosmetics,
things like that?
So I will say it was a
regret in the first year.
I sort of wished I had
kept track of all of that.
And not because it's earth
shattering information.
It doesn't even matter to
anyone else except for me.
But having that information
now, tracking that for a year,
it really helped
me figure out sort
of like an semi-average female
consumer-- how much stuff
am I actually using?
Which then-- it just
keeps preventing me
from making impulse purchases.
I know that I don't
need to go stock up
on stuff, because
it takes a long time
to actually use things up.
So that was sort of a regret.
But one thing that
did happen was
four or four and a half months
into it, Black Friday came up.
And one of the things
that I had done
when I started the
shopping ban was I
unsubscribed from
basically everything.
And I also unfollowed all
retailers on social media.
So I thought I was doing great.
I wasn't really getting
those emails anymore.
I wasn't being told about
all the different things
I could buy.
So I thought I was doing good.
And then somehow,
Black Friday, I
got an email from my
favorite bookstore.
And I actually talked myself
into buying something.
So I talked myself into it.
And it was really this
exercise after that.
Because it happened so quickly.
And people call it
impulse purchases.
And in that moment, I was like,
I've actually done this a lot
before.
And it feels a lot more
like a blackout purchase,
where it's so quick.
And then all of a sudden you
have a confirmation email
that's like, here's
this thing you did.
You're like, wait I did what?
How much did I just spend?
So on Black Friday,
that happened.
So all of a sudden,
I see that I have
an e-reader, a confirmation
I have bought a new e-reader.
I immediately canceled
the order and then go,
what just happened?
And I realized there are
so many stories we tell
ourselves to justify something.
And it's not that the e-reader
would have been bad, per se.
Mine was broken.
So these are the stories
I was telling myself.
Mine was broken.
It did work.
But you had to-- you know
the reset pin, or little hole
you have to stick a pin in?
I had to do that every time
I wanted to turn it on.
So I sort of had to have a
pin available at all times.
So it sort of would
have helped me.
But I didn't need it.
I didn't actually need it.
So I'm telling myself
all this stuff.
And like, you haven't bought
yourself anything in so long.
And you've never seen
it this low before
in price and all this stuff.
It happened so quickly.
And then you just
make the purchase.
And so I think it
wasn't a regret.
Because actually
something I realized
that year was that,
past me, any time I
would have sort of screwed up
a challenge or gone off track,
old me would have been really
hard on myself and sort of just
shamed myself and made myself
feel really, really bad for it.
And that was the
first time I was like,
I have to take this as a
learning experience instead,
figure out what just happened,
so that going forward I
can just start
changing my behavior
or becoming more cognizant.
Like in that
specific example of--
what are the stories
I tell myself
before thinking about
making a purchase?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is probably quite
a difficult question.
But I wondered, having
gone through everything
you've gone through and thinking
about everything in the way
that you have, what are
your thoughts on how
far your behavior
in the past was
kind of innate human behavior?
Or how much was it based on the
context we all find ourselves
in now where there's so
much stuff available?
CAIT FLANDERS: No, it's
a really good question.
So it's sort of two parts.
Part of it is I don't know.
Because I don't know
what my old spending was.
When I got into
debt, especially,
I never tracked
spending in my life.
I just kept seeing that
my balance was growing,
and I stopped--
I truly-- it was so bad.
I stopped looking
at my credit cards.
I just saw that the
balance was growing,
and as long as I could
make the minimum payment,
I felt like I was
going to be OK.
And so I don't know,
honestly, what old me really
spent money on.
I'm guessing there was
probably not only social--
influence from things like
social media, but just
generally social influence.
When your friends are doing
something, you just do it, too.
I also know parts
of my debt came
from partying too much,
or just in the sense of I
never wanted to say no.
So any time some friends
asked me to hang out,
I would just say
yes, even if it meant
I was putting it on credit.
So I don't know.
I'm sure there's a mix
of kind of both there.
But I do know at
the end of the day,
when I look at some of the
things that I was buying
and some of the stuff
I was putting money
on-- and especially
with parting--
so much of my self-worth
was wrapped up in the fact
that I was a really
good partier and people
loved partying with me.
And I truly-- as soon
as I quit drinking,
I almost had an identity
crisis of just, like,
I don't even know
what I'm good at
or why people would want
to be friends with me
or want to hang out with me.
Because that was my life.
My life was so revolved
around partying
that I just didn't get it.
So not only in trying
to figure that out
and then de-cluttering and
looking at some of my stuff,
I'm like, there's
so much stuff I used
to do for the wrong reason.
I just didn't understand
who I was as a person.
And in starting to just
kind of let stuff go,
that was the first time I
really started to figure it out.
And I'm like, the
answers were so simple.
I'm like, I'm a writer.
I'm a reader.
So I like books.
I'm a writer.
I'm a reader.
I hike a lot.
I'm a sister.
I'm a friend.
I'm a daughter.
Who I am, they're actually
all pretty simple things.
And so once I sort of
figured that stuff out,
it just made
spending easier now.
But old me, I don't know.
I'd say a big mix.
AUDIENCE: How regiment did
you go when you first started?
Were you watching
how much water you
were using in the shower
and that sort of--
or is it just spending?
CAIT FLANDERS: Just spending.
AUDIENCE: Just spending.
CAIT FLANDERS: Yeah, yeah.
No, just spending.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
No, it's a good
question, though,
because that's sort
of a topic in general
that's pretty hot
right now, too,
of extreme frugality and
the things that people
will do to sort of cut back.
That, for me, has never
quite aligned with who I am
or what I'm about.
Because like I said, I
still went to restaurants.
And I bought something
if I needed it.
There were a few
things that year--
and I think women can
probably relate to this--
I only owned one pair of jeans.
And they ripped in
the inner thigh.
That only lasts for so long.
You can only fix
that so many times
before you have to replace that.
So no, it wasn't about
spending no money.
It was really for the first
time having to ask myself
why I'm thinking of
buying something.
I almost think, too--
make a visual of it.
It was kind of putting
a barrier between me
and every single purchase where
you almost are hitting a pause
button and asking
yourself a few questions
before you're doing it.
So instead of just automatically
making the purchase,
getting the thing, it was kind
of like hitting pause and just
going, huh, do I
really need this thing?
What's going on in
my head right now?
How am I feeling?
What's going on in my life?
What influencers are
around me right now?
What's going on?
But yeah.
SPEAKER: Any more questions?
Well, thank you very
much for that, Cait.
CAIT FLANDERS: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Let's give Cait
a round of applause.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CAIT FLANDERS: Thank
you for having me.